In Toronto, every arrival is a statement, and nothing says it better than this. Cadillac Optic was the number one selling luxury EV in Canada for 2025. Find your rhythm across a seamless 33-inch display and an immersive 19-speaker AKG surround audio system. This city demands agility, and Optic delivers with precision to make every drive extraordinary. Let's take the Cadillac. Find out more at Cadillac canada.ca. Luxury sales claim based on S&P Global Mobility Canadian New Vehicle Total Registrations for calendar year 2025 for the Cadillac definition of luxury. Every year, millions of people go through harrowing medical experiences.
在多伦多，每一次抵达都是一种宣言，而没有什么比这更能说明一切了。凯迪拉克Optic是2025年加拿大最畅销的豪华电动车。在无缝衔接的33英寸显示屏和身临其境的19扬声器AKG环绕声音响系统中寻找你的节奏。这座城市需要灵活性，而Optic以精准的表现让每一次驾驶都非同寻常。让我们开凯迪拉克吧。请登录Cadillac canada.ca了解更多信息。豪华车销量声明基于标普全球移动（S&P Global Mobility）2025历年加拿大新车总注册量对凯迪拉克豪华车定义的统计。每年，数以百万计的人经历痛苦的医疗体验。
From chemotherapy to a stay in the ICU, to a difficult childbirth, to the frustration of dealing with chronic pain, these experiences can leave scars on our minds as well as our bodies. Today we're going to talk with a psychologist who studies medical trauma and works with patients recovering from serious illnesses. We'll discuss what kinds of experiences can cause medical trauma, how common is it, and why is it so often overlooked? What mental health symptoms can it cause?
从化疗到入住重症监护室（ICU），再到艰难的分娩，以及应对慢性疼痛的沮丧，这些经历不仅会在我们的身体上，也会在我们的心灵上留下创伤。今天，我们将与一位研究医疗创伤并与从重病中恢复的患者合作的心理学家进行交谈。我们将讨论什么样的经历会导致医疗创伤，它的常见程度如何，以及为什么它经常被忽视？它会导致哪些心理健康症状？
Are there interventions and treatments that can help people heal? And if this is something you're experiencing in your own life, where can you go for help? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Jim Jackson, a licensed psychologist and research professor of medicine at Vanderbilt University Medical Center. Dr. Jackson is the co-founder and director of behavioral health at Vanderbilt's ICU Recovery Center, one of the world's first centers devoted
是否有干预和治疗方法可以帮助人们康复？如果你在自己的生活中也经历过这种情况，你可以去哪里寻求帮助？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理学科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我今天的嘉宾是吉姆·杰克逊（Jim Jackson）博士，他是一名持证心理学家，也是范德堡大学医学中心（Vanderbilt University Medical Center）的精神医学研究教授。杰克逊博士是范德堡大学ICU康复中心的联合创始人和行为健康主任，该中心是世界上最早致力于
to diagnosing and treating survivors of critical illness. He is a leading researcher on how serious illness affects the brain and mental health. He's published more than 150 research papers, and his work has been covered by media outlets, including the New York Times, Scientific American, the Atlantic, the Wall Street Journal, CNN, and PBS. His new book published in April is called Reclaiming Your Life from Medical Trauma, Recognize the Symptoms, Find the Treatment That Works, and heal your brain and body.
诊断和治疗重症幸存者的中心之一。他是关于重病如何影响大脑和心理健康的顶尖研究人员。他发表了150多篇研究论文，他的工作受到了包括《纽约时报》、《科学美国人》、《大西洋月刊》、《华尔街日报》、CNN和PBS在内的多家媒体的报道。他于4月出版的新书名为《从医疗创伤中重获新生：识别症状，找到有效的治疗方法，并治愈你的大脑和身体》（Reclaiming Your Life from Medical Trauma, Recognize the Symptoms, Find the Treatment That Works, and heal your brain and body）。
Dr. Jackson, thank you for joining me today. I'm really delighted to be here. Thank you for having me on. Let's start as we often do with a definition. What exactly is medical trauma, and when people think of traumatic events, they often think of things like war or abuse, but can relatively common medical events cause similar traumatic reactions.
杰克逊博士，非常感谢你今天能来。我真的很高兴能来到这里。谢谢你邀请我。让我们像往常一样从一个定义开始。究竟什么是医疗创伤？当人们想到创伤性事件时，他们通常会想到战争或虐待之类的事件，但是相对常见的医疗事件是否也会引起类似的创伤反应呢？
I'll tackle the second part of your question first, and the first part, second. Okay. I do think for a long time, people have had pretty specific notions of what constitutes trauma, and those notions have included things like combat and sexual abuse or sexual assault. And of course, of course, those things are hugely tremendous. but I think it's important to note that there are a range of experiences, including in the medical domain, that are also traumatic, that are also often hugely traumatic, and those problems are often overlooked. When we think of a definition of medical trauma, it's a little
我先回答你问题的第二部分，然后再回答第一部分。好的。我认为在很长一段时间里，人们对构成创伤的概念有相当具体的看法，这些概念包括战斗、性虐待或性侵犯等。当然，当然，这些事情是巨大的、极具破坏性的。但我认为重要的是要注意到，有一系列经历，包括在医疗领域的经历，也是创伤性的，通常也具有巨大的创伤性，而这些问题往往被忽视了。当我们思考医疗创伤的定义时，它有点
bit complicated. There are a variety of ways that people talk about this phenomenon, but in general, I think of medical trauma as the emotional and physical and even the cognitive distress that is borne out of difficult medical experiences and also difficult medical encounters. I think there are two mistakes that we fall into when we talk about trauma that some people could fall into. One would be to see it behind every tree, because it's not behind every tree. It's not the cause of every ill. One would be not to see it anywhere.
复杂。人们谈论这种现象的方式有很多种，但总的来说，我认为医疗创伤是由困难的医疗经历以及困难的医疗接触所产生的精神、身体甚至是认知上的痛苦。当我们谈论创伤时，我们可能会陷入两个误区，有些人可能会陷入其中。一个是认为它无处不在，因为它并非无处不在。它不是所有疾病的根源。另一个是认为它哪里都不存在。
That's a mistake because trauma exists. And I have tried in my book and in my work to thread the needle, you know, not to see trauma again everywhere, not to overdiagnose it, but not to minimize it. And I think the experience of many in the medical arena is that their medical trauma has been minimized a bit. Yeah. What are some of the most common types of experiences that cause medical trauma? a few in the intro, but did I cover the waterfront? Yeah, you did cover some key ones. Critical illness would be an obvious one, right? When people are on a ventilator, they're in that
这是一个错误，因为创伤是真实存在的。我在书里和工作中一直在努力走一条平衡的道路，你知道，既不要到处看到创伤，不要过度诊断它，但也不要将其最小化。我认为许多人在医疗领域的体验是，他们的医疗创伤在一定程度上被最小化了。是的。导致医疗创伤的最常见经历有哪些？我在引言中提到了几个，但我涵盖全面了吗？是的，你确实涵盖了一些关键的方面。重病将是一个明显的例子，对吧？当人们戴上呼吸机时，他们就属于
category of the sickest of the sick, as many of our patients are. That is frequently a cause of medical trauma. A difficult cancer journey is often a cause of medical trauma. An emergency C-section is a cause of medical trauma, a surgery that didn't go well. Those are, are obvious things. I think there also are more subtle things. A chronic illness that has this drip, drip, drip, this constant quality doesn't go away, derails your life. Might not result in PTSD necessarily, but the people living with it consider it traumatic. The experience of being minimized, being a person who is encountering gaslighting again and again and again. That, I think, can be traumatic. These experiences are often not only traumatic for patients, but also for families,
病情最严重的那类人群，正如我们的许多患者一样。这经常是医疗创伤的诱因。艰难的癌症抗争之旅通常是医疗创伤的诱因。紧急剖腹产是医疗创伤的诱因，手术不顺利也是。这些都是显而易见的事情。我认为还有一些更微妙的事情。一种慢性的疾病，它像滴水穿石一样，具有这种持续的特质，挥之不去，扰乱了你的生活。它不一定会导致创伤后应激障碍（PTSD），但与之共存的人认为它是创伤性的。被最小化的经历，成为一个一次又一次遭遇煤气灯操纵（gaslighting）的人。我认为，这可能是创伤性的。这些经历往往不仅对患者是创伤性的，对家属也是如此，
for families who are not living the trauma, but they're observing it. So a huge array of experiences, some of them, not the ones that we think of, some of them obvious. And that raises the issue of whether a family member can experience medical trauma as a result of living with somebody who has gone through something like this. I mean, is that also common? It's quite common two decades ago or so. There was a great paper by a French intensivist, and the first paper was about the impact of critical illness, not on patients, but on family members. And that paper and others since then have demonstrated that rates of PTSD are almost as high, in some cases even higher in family members than in patients. And I see this quite a bit. I, I, I, I,
对那些没有经历创伤但正在观察创伤的家属来说也是如此。因此，有一大堆经历，其中有些不是我们想到的那些，有些则是显而易见的。这就提出了一个问题：家庭成员是否会因为与经历过此类事情的人共同生活而经历医疗创伤？我的意思是，这也是常见的情况吗？这相当普遍。大约二十年前左右。法国的一位重症监护医师写了一篇出色的论文，第一篇论文是关于重病对患者的影响，但不是对患者，而是对家庭成员的影响。那篇论文以及自那以后的其他论文已经证明，在某些情况下，家庭成员中PTSD的发病率几乎和患者一样高，甚至更高。我经常看到这种情况。我，我，我，
interact with patients and families at the clinic. And sometimes the patients say, I don't remember any of my experience in the ICU. And I'm so glad. And their family members say, I remember every moment of that experience. And I'm so sad. And I think we need to honor not only the experience of patients, but also of families. And to acknowledge that in many ways, medical trauma can be not just an individual problem, but very much a family problem. How common is medical trauma? Do we have good estimates of its prevalence? There are hundreds and a few thousand papers that I would say are broadly about medical trauma, and many of those are epidemiologic studies that look at prevalence rates of things like
在诊所与患者和家属互动。有时患者会说，我不记得我在ICU的任何经历。我太高兴了。他们的家属却说，我记得那段经历的每一个瞬间。我太难过了。我认为我们不仅需要尊重患者的经历，也需要尊重家属的经历。并承认在许多方面，医疗创伤不仅可以是一个人的问题，很大程度上也可以是一个家庭的问题。医疗创伤有多常见？我们有关于其患病率的良好估计吗？有成百上千篇我认为大致关于医疗创伤的论文，其中许多是流行病学研究，探讨了诸如
PTSD in particular. If you look at PTSD, not the only problem that, develops from medical trauma, but one, the rates are astonishingly high. If you look at the ICU, for instance, where millions of people go every year in North America, typically about six million people are admitted to the ICU, the estimates of PTSD would be somewhere between 10 or 12 percent on the low end and 20 or 22 percent on the high end. If you look at birth trauma, relatively significant rates of PTSD exist, and those are you, you, get higher as people move toward, again, difficulties like emergency C-sections. If you look at cardiac arrests, PTSD is common. If you look at anaphylaxis, if you look at cancer, in some cases
尤其是PTSD等问题的患病率。如果你看一下PTSD，它并不是医疗创伤发展而来的唯一问题，但却是其中之一，其发病率高得惊人。例如，如果你看看ICU，每年在北美有数百万人进入ICU，通常大约有六00万人入住ICU，PTSD的估计值在低端大约是10%到12%，高端则是20%到22%。如果你看看分娩创伤，存在相对显著的PTSD发病率，而且当你转向像紧急剖腹产这样的困难情况时，这些比率会更高。如果你看看心脏骤停，PTSD很常见。如果你看看过敏性休克，如果你看看癌症，在某些情况下
these rates of trauma are very much in line with the rates of things like PTSD that we see in combat veterans. So it's a not insignificant problem. I try to be conservative when I discuss it, But it's not uncommon in the literature and in my own experience to see significant PTSD in one in five patients in a given population of people who have encountered a difficult medical situation. And of course, those rates depend on things like risk factors. If you've had trauma before, before the event, you're more likely to have it after. If you're in a high risk group before, you're more likely to develop it after. It's a hugely common problem. So that it kind of indicates that you can, you have some idea of who might be at risk for medical trauma.
这些创伤的发病率与我们在战斗老兵身上看到的像PTSD这样的发病率非常吻合。所以这不是一个微不足道的问题。我在讨论它时尽量保持保守，但在文献和我自己的经验中，在经历过困难医疗状况的特定人群中，五分之一的患者出现显著的PTSD并不罕见。当然，这些比率取决于风险因素等。如果你在事件发生前曾经经历过创伤，你之后更有可能经历创伤。如果你在事件发生前属于高风险群体，你之后更有可能患上该病。这是一个非常普遍的问题。所以这在某种程度上表明，你可以，你对谁可能面临医疗创伤的风险有一些了解。
So people who have had PTSD or other types of trauma before. But are there other characteristics that you would look for before somebody undergoes, say, a significant medical procedure where they are likely to come out with trauma? Young age is often a concern. You know, in many cases, young age is considered a good thing. You know, I miss my 20s. Young age is a good thing. But the younger you are, the more foreign the idea of being very ill is. You know, when you're 60 or 70 or certainly 80, if there are significant medical problems that you encounter, you're bracing for those, right? You know about those, right? Like you've lost some friends already, whatever the case. but if you're 20 and you land in the ICU, if you're 30 and you're now contemplating death,
所以，以前患过PTSD或其他类型创伤的人。但是，在一个人接受例如可能导致创伤的重大医疗程序之前，你还会寻找哪些其他特征呢？年轻往往是一个令人担忧的问题。你知道，在许多情况下，年轻被认为是一件好事。你知道，我怀念我的20多岁。年轻是一件好事。但是你越年轻，患重病的想法就越陌生。你知道，当你60岁、70岁或当然还有80岁时，如果你遇到重大的医疗问题，你是在做心理准备的，对吧？你对这些有所了解，对吧？就像你已经失去了一些朋友一样，无论情况如何。但是如果你20岁却进了ICU，如果你30岁，现在正在面对死亡，
the dynamic is very different for you than it is for someone in their 70s or 80s. So when I'm in the ICU seeing patients as I do a couple days a week, I'm always particularly concerned not only about the 85-year-old, but about the 35-year-old. Because for them and for their family, for their parents and their children, and the thought of things not ending well is much more arresting than it is for someone who reflects on 80 years of a life well lived. Well, that certainly makes sense. Now, in your book, you talk about seven categories of medical trauma. Can you briefly summarize what these are? Sure. When I talked about seven categories, I referred to the sorts of things that often are the
你的动态与七八十岁的人非常不同。因此，当我像一周几天那样在ICU看望患者时，我总是特别关心的不仅是85岁的老人，还有35岁的人。因为对他们以及他们的家人、他们的父母和孩子来说，事情没有好结果的想法比那些回顾自己度过了美好80年人生的人要震撼得多。嗯，这确实说得通。现在，在你的书中，你谈到了医疗创伤的七个类别。你能简要总结一下这些是什么吗？当然。当我谈到七个类别时，我指的是那些经常是医疗创伤的形式、
forms of medical trauma, the causes. And again, those can be things like a surgery that happened, a medical event that happened. They can be things like an illness that developed. They can be things again like the experience of being dismissed or minimized by a provider. I've tried to move away from a situation where medical trauma is caused by just one thing. truth is caused by a wide variety of things. And those experiences, again, major surgery, the development of a chronic illness, a difficult experience with health care. They may lead to medical trauma or they may not. And I think that's important. There are a lot of paradoxes that we see. And by that, I mean, there are some people who have exposure to a gigantic dose of trauma. And they seem
诱因的事情。再次强调，这些可以是发生的手术、发生的医疗事件。它们可以是某种疾病的发展。它们也可以像再次经历被医疗提供者忽视或最小化的体验一样。我一直在试图摆脱医疗创伤仅仅由一件事引起的局面。事实是它由各种各样的因素引起。而这些经历，再次强调，大手术、慢性病的发生、与医疗保健的不愉快经历。它们可能会导致医疗创伤，也可能不会。我认为这一点很重要。我们看到了很多悖论。我的意思是，有些人接触了巨量的创伤。而他们似乎
pretty okay. And there are some people who were exposed to quite a mild dose, what we might consider quite a mild dose of medical trauma. And they're not. And I think that mimics what we see in the veterans that I have worked with over many years, where some people are on multiple deployments exposed to a great deal of combat seem to be relatively okay. And some people have relatively mild exposure to a shelling or a rocket landing near their base. And they develop significant PTSD from this. So I think it's important to be rigorous on the one hand in how we define trauma. On the other hand, to be slow to gate keep.
表现得挺好。还有一些人接触了相当温和的剂量，我们可能认为是相当温和的医疗创伤剂量。但他们却表现不好。我认为这模仿了我在多年共事的老兵身上看到的情况，有些人经历了多次部署，接触了大量的战斗，似乎相对还好。而有些人对在其基地附近爆炸的炮弹或火箭弹的接触相对较轻。他们却因此发展出显著的PTSD。因此，我认为一方面在如何定义创伤方面要严格，这是很重要的。另一方面，在设置门槛时要谨慎。
You know, I think we really don't want to say to someone, you know, this experience doesn't quite measure up, doesn't quite count because you were only in the hospital for four days and you have to be in the hospital for 44 days. These are very individual experiences that people have, and sometimes they're surprised by how traumatic those experiences are. So is there a checklist of symptoms that you look for when you're diagnosing this? In my head, I'm always interested in what the functional impact is. I think that's how psychologists think about this, and the DSM reflects it as well. Now, of course, there's no diagnosis, no formal diagnosis, which is medical trauma.
你知道，我认为我们真的不想对某人说，你知道，这段经历不太符合标准，不算数，因为你只在医院待了四天，而你必须在医院待44天。这些都是人们拥有的非常个人化的体验，有时他们会对这些经历具有多大的创伤性感到惊讶。那么，在诊断时，你有什么症状清单可循吗？在我的脑海里，我总是对功能上的影响感兴趣。我认为心理学家就是这样思考的，DSM（《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》）也反映了这一点。现在，当然，没有一种诊断，没有正式的诊断叫做医疗创伤。
But at the end of the day, I think we're really concerned about the impact. Not simply do you have nine out of 14 symptoms or 17 out of 20 or whatever it might be, but rather, how do these symptoms show up in your relationships? How do they show up in your relationship with your body? How do they show up in the way you engage your family? how do they show up in the way you engage your work? And often the way that medical trauma shows up is in particularly profound avoidance. It's not the only way, but it's a prominent way.
但归根结底，我认为我们真正关心的是其影响。不仅是你是否有14种症状中的9种，或者是20种中的17种，无论可能是什么，而是，这些症状如何体现在你的人际关系中？它们如何体现在你与身体的关系中？它们如何体现在你与家人的互动方式中？它们如何体现在你投入工作的方式中？通常，医疗创伤表现出来的方式是特别深远的逃避。这不是唯一的方式，但却是一个突出的方式。
And that is patients often don't want to go to the doctors because that's like returning to the scene of the crime. Last place they want to be, they don't want to go to the OBGYN's office to engage the stenographer because that's where they found out that that baby they were looking forward to having didn't have a heartbeat anymore. And they don't want to have that happen again. And in some cases, they don't want to go to the ER because that's where they had a heart attack. And the insidious impact of that is that if you need to go to the ER, but you decide not to go to the ER, a lot of bad things can happen.
那就是患者经常不想去看医生，因为那就像重返犯罪现场。那是他们最不想去的地方，他们不想去妇产科诊所面对超声医师，因为正是在那里他们发现他们一直期盼的那个婴儿没有心跳了。他们不想让这种事情再次发生。在某些情况下，他们不想去急诊室，因为那是他们心脏病发作的地方。这种做法的潜移默化的影响是，如果你需要去急诊室，但你决定不去急诊室，很多糟糕的事情就会发生。
Many years ago, I'll share a quick anecdote. I had a little car. We had moved in Nashville. I had a little car. And one day the check engine light came on. And I was in a hurry. I didn't want to deal with it. And so I had a post-it note in the car.
很多年前，我分享一个简短的轶事。我有一辆小汽车。我们搬到了纳什维尔。我有一辆小汽车。有一天，发动机故障灯亮了。我很赶时间。我不想处理它。所以我在车里贴了一张便签纸，
I put it over the check engine light and I just kept driving. And it seemed fine. It seemed very fine. And one day, three or four months later, my car broke down by the side of the road and the engine seized up. And a day later, I sold it to the scrapyard for $50, as I recall. And this is a phenomenon, this avoidance, that we see with some of our patients, which is, hey, you really need to deal with this. But for a variety of reasons, you're choosing to put it off. And I understand it.
我把它贴在发动机故障灯上，然后我继续开车。看起来很好。看起来非常好。有一天，三四个月后，我的车在路边抛锚了，发动机卡死了。一天后，我把它以50美元的价格卖给了废品回收站，我记得是这样。这是一种现象，这种逃避，我们在一些患者身上看到了，也就是，嘿，你真的需要处理这个问题。但出于各种原因，你选择拖延。我理解它。
I can empathize with it very well. But the more you put off things that you need to address, the worse the outcomes are going to be. And I think that's what we see in medical trauma. Avoidance is a common phenomenon and an unhelpful one. You mentioned a moment ago that medical trauma is not in the DSM. Is that a problem? Should it be its own category in the DSM? I don't know if it should be.
我能对它感同身受。但你越是拖延你需要解决的事情，结果就会越糟糕。我认为这就是我们在医疗创伤中看到的。逃避是一种普遍现象，也是一种无益的现象。你刚才提到医疗创伤不在DSM中。这是一个问题吗？它应该成为DSM中的一个独立类别吗？我不知道它是否应该。
PTSD is certainly a category in the DSM and anxiety and depression, which are the two other primary problems that we see on the heels of medical trauma are in the DSM. Those are probably the three horsemen of the apocalypse, if you will, as it relates to medical trauma, anxiety. and depression and anxiety and depression and PTSD. So I don't know that it needs a separate diagnosis, but I do think what we need to do a little bit more fully
PTSD当然是DSM中的一个类别，焦虑和抑郁也是，这是我们在医疗创伤之后看到的另外两个主要问题，它们都在DSM中。如果可以这么说的话，这些可能是末日四骑士中与医疗创伤相关的三个，焦虑和抑郁，以及焦虑和抑郁和PTSD。所以我不认为它需要一个单独的诊断，但我确实认为我们需要更全面地做的一件事是
is to recognize that many of these DSM categories do indeed apply to people on the heels of medical trauma. And I think often because well-meaning practitioners, well-meaning physicians, for instance, because they don't have a mental framework for what medical trauma is, they're often not asking a patient after a difficult medical event. Are you anxious? Are you depressed? Do you have symptoms of PTSD? Sometimes that conversation takes place right after the event, right? Right after distressing event. But we know that PTSD by definition doesn't develop a day after that event, right? It doesn't develop a week after the event, it takes some time. So often, by the time these problems have developed, people are no longer in the clinic, and no one is really asking about them. And for that reason, they fly under the
认识到许多这些DSM类别确实适用于医疗创伤之后的患者。而且我认为通常是因为善意的从业者，例如善意的医生，因为他们没有关于什么是医疗创伤的心理框架，所以在经历了一次艰难的医疗事件后，他们经常不问患者。你焦虑吗？你抑郁吗？你有PTSD的症状吗？有时这种对话发生在事件刚发生后，对吧？就在令人痛苦的事件发生后。但我们知道，根据定义，PTSD在事件发生后的一天内是不会发展的，对吧？它在事件发生后的一周内也不会发展，这需要一些时间。所以通常，当这些问题发展出来时，人们已经不在诊所了，也没有人真正询问它们。由于这个原因，它们逃过了
radar. And often patients, I would say this, often patients, particularly in the context of a surgery or a life-saving situation, they're grateful, in the moment especially, they're grateful. I survived this transplant, right? I have a new lease on life. And only later, did they realize, oh, by the way, now I have some brand new problems that I didn't have before, right? Now I'm having nightmares after the surgery. I didn't have them before. And patients often feel like they're in quite a quandary. And that quandary is, I think I'm supposed to be really grateful for being alive. I think I'm supposed to be really grateful to my oncologist for saving my life. And if I'm supposed to be really grateful, maybe that means I shouldn't be complaining, right? And they talk
雷达。而且通常患者会这样说，通常患者，特别是在手术或挽救生命的救治背景下，他们心存感激，尤其是在当下的那一刻，他们心存感激。我从这次移植手术中存活下来了，对吧？我获得了新生。只有在后来，他们才意识到，哦，顺便说一句，现在我有一些以前没有的崭新问题了，对吧？现在我在手术后开始做噩梦了。我以前没有过。患者常常觉得他们陷入了相当大的困境。而这个困境是，我想我应该对活着感到非常感激。我想我应该对我的肿瘤科医生救了我的命感到非常感激。如果我应该感到非常感激，也许这意味着我不应该抱怨，对吧？他们说服
themselves out of the difficulties they're having because they somehow don't seem legitimate. And I think an important message, an important message to your listeners is if you're struggling, give yourself space and permission to struggle, right? Don't push those negative feelings out of your awareness just because you feel like you need to be filled with gratitude all the time. You know, acknowledge them and attend to them. We can help you address some Two things can be true at the same time, right? You can be grateful to be alive and you can be angry and you can be sad. And that's important.
自己不要去想遇到的困难，因为这些困难在某种程度上似乎不合情理。我认为一个重要的信息，一个对你的听众很重要的信息是，如果你在挣扎，给自己留出空间和允许自己去挣扎的权利，对吧？不要仅仅因为你觉得自己必须时刻充满感激，就把那些负面情绪推出你的意识之外。你知道，承认它们并关注它们。我们可以帮你解决一些……两件事可以同时为真，对吧？你可以为活着而感激，你也可以感到愤怒，你也可以感到悲伤。这很重要。
We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk to Dr. Jackson about treatments for medical trauma and where people can go for help. This episode is brought to you by L'Oreal Group. Beauty is a powerful force that moves us. That's why Loreal Group has built a business that is inclusive at its heart with 100% of its brands, championing diversity. With 25,000 professional opportunities for people under 30 worldwide and 54% of leading positions held by women, diversity is a strength that helps L'Oreal Group create the best beauty products for all people. Visit Loreal.com to learn more.
我们将进行短暂的休息。回来后，我将与杰克逊博士谈论医疗创伤的治疗方法以及人们可以去哪里寻求帮助。本集由欧莱雅集团（L'Oreal Group）赞助播出。美是一种感动我们的强大力量。这就是为什么欧莱雅集团建立了一家以包容为核心的业务，其100%的品牌都倡导多样性。在全球范围内，为30岁以下的人群提供25,000个专业机会，且54%的管理层职位由女性担任，多样性是一种力量，帮助欧莱雅集团为所有人创造最好的美妆产品。访问Loreal.com了解更多信息。
So let's talk about treatments. If somebody has medical trauma or maybe thinks they have it, where do they go for help? What are the treatments that work? As a proud psychologist, I, of course, believe the psychologists have so much to offer. And we're not the only ones who do, of course. But we have a lot to offer. And as it relates to trauma, we have a lot to offer. Now, it's important, again, to remember that medical trauma doesn't always result in PTSD, right? It typically doesn't.
那么我们来谈谈治疗。如果有人有医疗创伤或者可能认为自己有，他们去哪里寻求帮助？哪些治疗方法是有效的？作为一名骄傲的心理学家，我当然相信心理学家能提供很多帮助。当然，我们并不是唯一能提供帮助的人。但我们有很多可以提供的。就创伤而言，我们有很多可以提供的。现在，再次记住，医疗创伤并不总是导致PTSD，这一点很重要，对吧？它通常不会。
You know, even in the references that I made where there might be 18% of ICU survivors who have PTSD, not very good at math, but that means that 82% don't, right? So most people don't. But the number who do for those is a huge problem. So I think if you have PTSD, thoughtful treatments for PTSD are likely effective. You know, prolonged exposure can be effective. Cognitive processing therapy can be effective. Interpersonal and psychodiamph therapies can be effective.
你知道，即使在我提到的那些参考数据中，可能有18%的ICU幸存者患有PTSD，我数学不太好，但这意味着82%的人没有，对吧？所以大多数人没有。但对于那些患病的人来说，人数却是一个巨大的问题。所以我认为如果你有PTSD，针对PTSD的深思熟虑的治疗可能是有效的。你知道，持续暴露疗法可能是有效的。认知加工疗法可能是有效的。人际关系和心理动力学疗法可能是有效的。
There may be nuances. there may be differences that reflect the vagaries and uniquenesses of medical trauma. But I think in general, thoughtful trauma treatment is probably effective for medical trauma. With that said, if you force me to pick one therapy that I particularly like for people after medical trauma, it is acceptance and commitment therapy. That's been the approach with my patients. that seems to resonate the most. Again, not necessarily for people with PTSD,
可能会有一些细微差别。可能会有一些差异，反映了医疗创伤的变幻莫测和独特性。但我认为总的话，深思熟虑的创伤治疗对医疗创伤可能是有效的。话虽如此，如果你强迫我选择一种我特别喜欢用于医疗创伤患者的疗法，那就是接纳承诺疗法（Acceptance and Commitment Therapy）。这就是我对待患者的方法。这似乎最能引起共鸣。当然，不一定适用于患有PTSD的人，
but often for people whose lives have been really derailed and they are very different than they used to be and they are trying to figure out how to make sense of things. The acceptance aspect of acceptance and commitment therapy is hugely valuable. So I love that. You can find acceptance and commitment therapy practitioners. You can find practitioners who treat trauma,
但通常适用于那些生活真正被打乱、与过去截然不同、正在努力弄清楚如何理解事物的人。接纳承诺疗法中的接纳方面具有巨大的价值。所以我很喜欢它。你可以找到接纳承诺疗法的执业者。你可以找到治疗创伤的执业者，
there are many of them. Now, patients struggle, and it's unfortunate because you go online, you Google a psychologist, a list of literally thousands of people come up. It's not really easy to pick them. People don't typically have medical trauma in their list of expertise. But I do think that's changing. I think that's changing over time. Let's talk for a little bit about acceptance and commitment.
他们有很多。现在，患者在挣扎，这很不幸，因为你上网，谷歌搜索一个心理学家，字面上会出现数千人的名单。挑选他们其实并不容易。人们的专长列表中通常没有医疗创伤。但我确实认为这正在改变。我认为这随着时间推移在改变。让我们花点时间谈谈接纳承诺
commitment therapy. I mean, I get the idea of accepting the idea that you have, you have this problem, but what are you committing to? Yeah, it's a great question. You know, my own journey, as I discuss in the book at length, is that I have OCD and I developed OCD. I would say I really developed it in spades in 2018 as a 50-year-old adult. I think looking back, I had probably had elements of it three decades before, but it really had been quiet. And when it came back, again, in Spades, I went to see a psychologist who is amazing and I said some version of, let's get rid of this. This should be no problem, right? Like, let's get rid of it. And she kindly, in so many words, said, you know, I'm not so sure that that's what we do. I'm not sure we really
疗法。我的意思是，我理解接受你有这个问题这个想法，但你承诺的是什么呢？是的，这是一个很好的问题。你知道，正如我在书中详细讨论的那样，我自己的经历是我有强迫症（OCD），我患上了强迫症。我想说我确实在2018年作为一个50岁的成年人大规模地患上了它。回想起来，我可能在三十年前就有它的迹象，但它真的很安静。当它再次卷土重来、而且是大规模卷土重来时，我去看了一位非常了不起的心理学家，我说了一些类似这样的话，让我们摆脱这个吧。这应该没问题，对吧？就像，让我们摆脱它吧。她好心地换着各种说法对我说，你知道，我不太确定这就是我们所做的。我不确定我们真的
get rid of it. You don't, you don't just pull it out like a weed, right? And so she invited me to begin to accept it and to deal with all the ramifications of that. And it took me a year, maybe a year and a half to even consider really accepting it. You know, this change can take a long time. When I did, things really began to change. And the commitment element of that was I'm going to find a way to commit to live my life with this new challenge in a way that reflects my values. I'm going to commit to a life that reflects my values.
能摆脱它。你不能像拔野草一样把它拔掉，对吧？所以她邀请我开始接受它并处理与之相关的所有后果。我花了整整一年，甚至一年半的时间才真正考虑接受它。你知道，这种改变可能需要很长时间。当我这样做时，事情真的开始改变了。而其中的承诺元素是，我将找到一种方法，以反映我价值观的方式，带着这个新的挑战继续我的生活。我将致力于过一种反映我价值观的生活。
And I'm going to commit to finding a way to live a rich life and a full life, even with these problems that I didn't ask for that I don't want. And that's been a beautiful thing that both andness of things, both and. And in my interaction with my patients, it's that both and that is often especially powerful. And that is, I've got a new problem now. I've got a new medical challenge now. I didn't have cancer before, but now I do. Or, you know, I wasn't on oxygen before, but now I am.
即使带着这些我没有要求、我也不想要的问题，我也要致力于找到一种过上丰富而充实的生活的方法。这是一个美丽的事情，事物的“既……又……”的二元性，既……又……。在我与患者的互动中，往往是这种“既……又……”显得尤为强大。那就是，我现在有了一个新问题。我现在有了一个新的医疗挑战。我以前没有癌症，但现在我有了。或者，你知道，我以前没有吸氧，但现在我有了。
I mean, you could fill in the blank. And I'm going to find a way to live a rich life, even with these difficulties that I didn't want. Early in the pandemic, we started a program, a support group program for long COVID patients. we've led five or six hundred support groups by now for people with long COVID. And very often the dynamic was patients were saying, I'm going to be okay once this long COVID goes away. Once it goes away, I'm going to be okay. And I understand the appeal of that, but the truth for many of them is actually it's not going away, right? It's not going away.
我的意思是，你可以填空。即使带着这些我不想要的困难，我也要找到一种过上丰富生活的方法。在疫情初期，我们启动了一个项目，一个针对长新冠（long COVID）患者的支持小组项目。到目前为止，我们已经为长新冠患者领导了五六百个支持小组。非常常见的情况是，患者会说，一旦这个长新冠消失，我就会好起来的。一旦它消失了，我就会好起来的。我理解这种想法的吸引力，但对他们中的许多人来说，事实其实是它不会消失，对吧？它不会消失。
So if you're waiting to be okay for it to go away, you're going to be okay for it to go away, you're going to be waiting actually a long time. So how can we, it's not as simple as just flipping a switch and changing your mind, but how can we invite you to consider the idea and then eventually embrace the idea that actually I can choose to be okay right now, right, even if it doesn't go away? And when patients have figured that out, that I can be okay, even if this never goes away, then you've really cracked the code and then you see them begin to really thrive. So what do you wish that health care providers, both physicians and mental health providers,
所以如果你在等待它消失以便自己好起来，你会好起来的，实际上你将会等待很长时间。那么我们如何能够，这并不像按一下开关改变主意那么简单，但我们如何能够邀请你考虑这个想法，然后最终拥抱这个想法：实际上我可以选择现在就感觉好起来，对吧，即使它没有消失？当患者想通了这一点——我即使这永远不会消失也能感觉好起来——那么你真的破解了这个密码，然后你会看到他们开始真正蓬勃发展。那么你希望医疗保健提供者，包括医生和心理健康提供者，
knew about medical trauma? Do you have any advice for clinicians who want to incorporate an awareness of this into their work with patients? I've got so many thoughts about this, and I know we're limited in time. I would really invite my physician colleagues, my health care colleagues, to be much more curious about this issue to focus a little less uniformly on medical outcomes and to focus a little more thoroughly on mental health outcomes. In the ICU, where I've done much of my work, I've seen this dynamic where patients survive the ICU and there's almost this thought that our work is finished, right?
对医疗创伤了解多少呢？对于想要将这种意识融入其患者工作的临床医生，你有什么建议吗？关于这一点我有很多想法，而且我知道我们的时间有限。我真的很想邀请我的医生同事、我的医疗保健同事，对这个问题保持更多的好奇心，少一些对医疗结果的单一关注，多一些对心理健康结果的彻底关注。在ICU，我做了很多工作，我看到了这样一种动态：患者在ICU幸存下来，几乎有这样一种想法：我们的工作已经完成了，对吧？
Like they're not on the ventilator anymore. They're breathing on their own. They've made it through this battle with sepsis, our work is finished. And I would invite my medical colleagues, whatever the disease might be, to think, you know, in some ways our work has just barely begun, right? It's far from finished. It's fantastic that they're alive. And some of our patients have said, and no doubt will say to me, well, sure, I'm alive, but if I knew I would have these problems, cognitive impairment and PTSD, anxiety, and depression, no job, you know, limited ability to work. I actually wish that I never would have made it out of the ICU.
就像他们不再需要呼吸机了。他们可以自己呼吸了。他们挺过了这场与败血症的战斗，我们的工作完成了。我会邀请我的医疗同事，无论是什么疾病，去思考，你知道，在某些方式上，我们的工作才刚刚开始，对吧？远未结束。他们还活着，这太棒了。我们的某些患者已经说过，毫无疑问也会对我说，当然，我还活着，但如果我知道我会遇到这些问题——认知障碍和PTSD、焦虑和抑郁，没有工作，你知道，工作能力有限。其实我希望我从来没有离开过ICU。
I mean, people say that. So deciding to ask a question, which is, how are you doing exactly? And, you know, do you feel any conflicted feelings and what's going on? And are you sad? And are you, you know, all of these sorts of things could take place quickly in the context of a busy PCPs office. And I think there needs to be more space for checking in with patients. with mental health challenges following a physical difficulty. Let's not, let's not make it an add on. Let's make this a central part of our process engaging people's mental health. For my
我的意思是，人们会这样说。所以决定问一个问题，那就是：你到底过得怎么样？而且，你知道，你有没有感到任何冲突的情绪？发生了什么？你难过吗？而且，你知道，所有这些类型的事情都可以在一个忙碌的初级保健医生（PCP）办公室里迅速发生。我认为在跟进由于身体困难而面临心理健康挑战的患者时，需要有更多的空间来进行沟通。让我们不要，让我们不要把它当作一个附加项。让我们把它作为我们关注人们心理健康过程的核心部分。对于我的
mental health colleagues, I would say, come on in, the water is fine, by which I mean, there's this huge issue. There are a relatively small number of us tackling it. Please join us, right? Come on in. The water's fine. You know, there are people with medical trauma. They want help and they need help. And to my psychologist friends and colleagues, you are uniquely equipped. You are uniquely equipped to be a cairn in the lives of these patients that points them toward a rich life. You know, you're uniquely equipped to be a guide. You're uniquely equipped to help them. No one is more equipped than you. They need your help. So come on in. The water is fine. and let's work together to transform the lives of people and families stuck in the throes of medical trauma as we help them try to find ways to reclaim their life.
心理健康同事，我想说，进来吧，水温正合适，我的意思是，这是一个巨大的问题。处理这个问题的我们数量相对较少。请加入我们，对吧？进来吧。水温正合适。你知道，有患有医疗创伤的人。他们需要帮助，他们也需要帮助。对于我的心理学家朋友和同事们，你们拥有独特的装备。你们拥有独特的装备，可以成为这些患者生命中的一座灯塔，引导他们走向丰富的生活。你知道，你们拥有独特的装备，可以成为向导。你们拥有独特的装备来帮助他们。没有人比你们更有装备。他们需要你们的帮助。所以进来吧。水温正合适。让我们共同努力，改变那些陷入医疗创伤困境的人和家庭的生活，帮助他们寻找重获新生的方法。
You know, I think it's interesting that you lead an ICU recovery center. How unusual is its existence and what are the other things that you work on there? Yeah, actually, that's a great question. So in the United Kingdom, probably as early as the early 2000s, there were at least a few recovery centers devoted to treating the unique constellation of problems that developed after the ICU. And my good friend, Dr. Carlos Stephen, great palmologist and intensivist researcher, she and I joined arms in 2013, and we formed the ICU Recovery Center at Vanderbilt, which I think, was the second clinic of its kind in the United States dealing, again, uniquely with the challenges of ICU survivors. And from a mental health standpoint, those include anxiety and depression, PTSD, sometimes OCD, sometimes psychosis, things of that sort. But typically the three horsemen
你知道，我觉得有趣的是你领导着一个ICU康复中心。它的存在有多么不寻常，你在那里还在从事哪些其他工作呢？是的，实际上，这是一个很好的问题。因此，在英国，可能早在2000年代初，就至少有几个康复中心专门治疗ICU之后出现的独特问题集合。我的好朋友卡洛斯·史蒂芬（Carlos Stephen）博士，一位杰出的肺科医师和重症监护研究员，她和我于2013年携手合作，我们在范德堡大学成立了ICU康复中心，我认为这是美国同类诊所中的第二家，同样专门处理ICU幸存者的挑战。从心理健康的视角来看，这些包括焦虑和抑郁、PTSD、有时是强迫症、有时是精神病，诸如此类的事情。但通常是末日四骑士，
of the apocalypse, and from a cognitive standpoint, often involve cognitive impairment. So in this clinic, We have a pharmacist. We have a palmologist and intensivist. We have a psychologist, me. And we engage people from a multifaceted standpoint, often helping them transition into finding resources. We have a social worker, by the way, Jenna McDonald, I should mention that. But on the heels of identifying problems, we often send them back to their community with a game plan, help them find. resources and when they find resources, they often do quite well. And one of the resources that in my
从认知的角度来看，通常涉及认知障碍。所以在诊所里，我们有一位药剂师。我们有一位肺科医师和重症监护医师。我们有一位心理学家，也就是我。我们从多个方面与人们接触，经常帮助他们过渡到寻找资源。顺便说一句，我们有一位社会工作者，珍娜·麦克唐纳（Jenna McDonald），我应该提到这一点。但在识别问题之后，我们通常会带着一个行动计划将他们送回社区，帮助他们寻找资源。而当他们找到资源时，他们的表现往往相当不错。而在我看来对这些患者至关重要的资源之一
mind is critical for these patients is support groups. So there are not, there are not thousands of support groups. But at Vanderbilt, we have at least a few, and there are a few around the country devoted to the needs of ICU survivors. We have a medical trauma support group as well, all offered virtually. And what I've learned, this is a new news. But what I've learned is that when people have more support, they do better, right? When they have less support, they do worse. And it's almost that simple. You know, there aren't that many axioms that I quickly subscribe to in psychology or elsewhere. But one of them, one thing that is axiomatic is, if you're having a mental health challenge and you have less support, it is harder, right? It's reliably
就是支持小组。因此，并没有，并没有成千上万的支持小组。但在范德堡大学，我们至少有几个，全国各地也有几个致力于满足ICU幸存者需求的小组。我们也有一个医疗创伤支持小组，全部以虚拟方式提供。而我所了解到的是，这是一个新消息。但我所了解到的是，当人们有更多的支持时，他们会做得更好，对吧？当他们得到的支持较少时，他们会做得更差。事情几乎就是这么简单。你知道，在心理学或其他领域，我很快赞同的公理并没有那么多。但其中之一，一个不证自明的事实是，如果你正在经历心理健康挑战并且得到的支持较少，那就更难，对吧？这确实
harder. And if you have more support, it's easier. And when we plug people into support groups with others whose stories are similar or perhaps the same, you see a light bulb go off and it's beautiful. And there is this dynamic of, I found my people, right? Like I've been encountering, I mean, I heard this just the other day from a patient. I've been encountering people from the point of view of the patient. This is what they say. I've been encountering people who say, you know, it's been six months, you should be done with this now, right? You should be doing better now, right? Like, you should be over your depression now. Like, really, you've got PTSD? Well-meaning friends and family. Those are painful things that patients hear. And when they engage people who equally have heard those
更难。而如果你有更多的支持，就会更容易。当我们把人们连接到与其他人的故事相似甚至相同的支持小组中时，你会看到一盏灯泡亮起，这太美妙了。并且存在这样一种动态：我找到了我的人，对吧？就像我一直在遇到，我的意思是，我刚刚从一个患者那里听到了这个。我一直从患者的角度遇到这样的人。这是他们所说的。我一直在遇到这样的人，他们说，你知道，已经六个月了，你现在应该结束了吧，对吧？你现在应该好起来了，对吧？就像，你现在应该克服抑郁了吧。真的，你得了PTSD？善意的朋友和家人。这些是患者听到的痛苦的事情。而当他们接触到同样听到这些事情并找到了继续前行的勇气和韧性的其他人时，当他们听到人们以如此美丽脆弱的方式谈论他们的挣扎时，他们觉得自己找到了自己的人。这些小组是，它们是实验室。它们远不止于此，但它们是我们患者学习和成长的实验室。如果有一件事我可以给予，如果我可以把精灵粉末撒在医疗创伤幸存者身上，那就是为他们创造丰富、有质感且有帮助的支持圈，因为这对于他们的成长至关重要。因此，总而言之，你现在在做什么？你还想回答哪些重大问题？你知道，有太多了。医疗创伤这个领域在许多方面
things and have found the courage and the resilience to shoulder on, when they see people speak with such beautiful vulnerability about their struggles, they feel like they've found their people. And these groups are, they're laboratories. They're much more than that, but they're laboratories for our patients to learn and to grow. And if there was one thing I could give, if there was pixie dust that I could sprinkle on medical trauma survivors, it would be to create rich and textured and helpful circle of support for them because it is critical to their growth. So just to wrap up, what are you working on now? What are the big questions that you would still like to answer? You know, there's so many. This field of medical trauma is in many ways
事情，并找到了继续前进的勇气和韧性。当他们看到人们以如此美丽而脆弱的方式谈论他们的挣扎时，他们觉得找到了属于自己的人。这些小组就是实验室。它们的意义远不止于此，但它们是我们的患者学习和成长的实验室。如果有什么东西我可以给予，如果有什么仙尘我可以撒在医疗创伤幸存者身上，那就是为他们建立一个丰富、有质感且有帮助的支持圈，因为这对他们的成长至关重要。总而言之，你现在在忙些什么？你还想解答哪些重大问题？你知道，有太多了。医疗创伤这个领域在许多方面
in its infancy. You know, when I decided to try to write this book, this medical trauma book, I thought, you know, surely someone has written a book for patients about medical trauma. and I thought, you know, I'm probably a little bit late to the party here, as I often have been in my life with good ideas, right? It's a great idea. And then I think, oh, gosh, someone else did it. So a psychologist from Cincinnati, Michelle Flom had written a great book about medical trauma a decade or so ago aimed at practitioners. That book's available. It's helpful.
处于萌芽阶段。你知道，当我决定尝试写这本书，这本关于医疗创伤的书时，我想，你知道，肯定有人为患者写过关于医疗创伤的书。而且我想，你知道，我可能在这个好主意上有点赶晚集了，就像我生活中经常做的那样，对吧？这是一个好主意。然后我想，哦，天哪，别人已经做过了。所以辛辛那提的一位心理学家米歇尔·弗洛姆在大约十年前写了一本关于医疗创伤的好书，旨在面向从业人员。那本书是可以买到的。很有帮助。
But no one had written a book aimed at patients. And so, you know, there's a book. now. It's about to be in the world in April, but I think our work is really only beginning. You know, I've got a lot of projects going on at any one time. There's, there's no next thing exactly, but it is to continue finding ways to lean into the challenges that people experience following medical trauma. And I think especially for me to convince my medical colleagues that this is a huge problem that they need to address. When I talk to people, about it, honestly, to medical colleagues, they're hugely open to the idea. When they hear about it,
但没有人写过一本面向患者的书。所以，你知道，现在有一本书了。它将于四月问世，但我认为我们的工作其实才刚刚开始。你知道，我同时在进行很多项目。并没有一个确切的下一步，但那就是继续寻找方法，去应对人们在经历医疗创伤后所面临的挑战。而且我认为对我来说，尤其是要说服我的医疗同仁们，这是一个他们需要解决的巨大问题。当我与人们谈论这件事时，坦率地说，与医疗同仁谈论时，他们对这个想法非常开放。当他们听到这个时，
they say, of course, that makes sense. But I have found that for many, unless you invite them to think about it, it's not necessarily on their radar. So I think one big area to improve is in this vast community of physicians, let's raise awareness. And I think also another area would be, let's figure out if there are particular treatments that we need to tailor for people with medical trauma, beyond the standard, beyond the usual, that will help transform the lives of people with medical trauma. Dr. Jackson, I want to thank you for joining me today. I think you've given our listeners a lot of very helpful information. It's really been a privilege to be with you. Thank you.
他们会说，当然，这说得很对。但我发现，对许多人来说，除非你邀请他们去思考这个问题，否则它不一定会出现在他们的雷达上。所以我认为需要改进的一个重要领域是在这个庞大的医生群体中，让我们提高意识。我认为另一个领域是，让我们弄清楚是否有我们需要为医疗创伤患者量身定制的特定治疗方法，超越标准，超越常规，这将有助于改变医疗创伤患者的生活。杰克逊博士，我要感谢你今天加入我们。我认为你为我们的听众提供了很多非常有用Информация。能和你在一起真的是一种荣幸。谢谢。
You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingofpsychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please subscribe and leave a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Do one of those media strategy people clicking through slides, scrolling spreadsheets?
你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 上，或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的平台上找到《心理学对话》以前的节目。如果你喜欢你所听到的内容，请订阅并留下一条评论。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，你可以发电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学对话》由李·韦内尔曼制作。感谢收听，我是美国心理学协会的金·米尔斯。你是那种浏览幻灯片、滚动电子表格的媒体策略人员吗？
Yes? Good. this is for you. Because on Spotify, there's an audience that's different, locked in, loyal, invested. They're called fans. Fans don't just listen to music. They feel seen by it, like it belongs to them.
是的？很好。这个就是为你准备的。因为在 Spotify 上，有一群不同的受众，他们全神贯注、忠诚、投入。他们被称为粉丝。粉丝不只是听音乐。他们从中感到被理解，仿佛音乐属于他们。
So when your brand shows up on Spotify, that's who you're talking to. And you're right next to artists like me, Lizzo. So, are you ready to talk to fans? Spotify Advertising. You're among fans. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以当你的品牌出现在 Spotify 上时，这就是你的对话对象。而且你就紧挨着像我这样的艺术家，比如莉佐。那么，你准备好和粉丝对话了吗？Spotify 广告。你在粉丝之中。本集节目还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。